tu penses que le diable pourrait être
une figure féminine ce que je pense
c'est que j'aime bien l'idée en fait que
le diable se soit pas quelque chose qui
d'apparence fait très peur et quelque
chose qui dit visuellement attention je
suis méchante j'aime bien l'idée que que
voilà que moi qui suis qu'un apparence
très innocente et très lisse finalement
on puisse être surpris par parce que je
dis et parce que je suis et t'as pas
peur que les féministes t'accuse en te
disant vous diabolisez la femme ou la
petite fille dans une heure ou à une
époque où on a tendance à faire hyper
attention à ce qu'on dit
non en fait c'est vrai que on dit on dit
plein de choses en fait il y a des gens
qui vont me dire qu'est-ce que c'est
choquant de tenir ses propos là en étant
une femme et inversement des gens qui
vont me dire qu'est-ce que ça fait du
bien en fait de se dire qu'on soit une
femme ou un homme on parle comme on veut
on dit ce qu'on veut peu importe le
sujet et moi je me sens plus proche de
ça on s'en fout qu'on soit un homme ou
une femme